my next guest is encouraging people
living with dementia and their carers to
get involved with music and create
playlists this Christmas evidence
suggests that listening to music with a
personal connection has huge benefits
for people living with dementia well my
guest is Lauren Laverne he knows a thing
or two about music and she is the
ambassador for music for dementia Lauren
hello hello and this is a lovely story
to be talking about in terms of a
positive message about dementia and we
talked about research showing the
positive impacts on people living with
dementia it's backed up by science isn't
it yeah no absolutely I mean I think we
all have an instinctive understanding
that music is good for us you know it
can be can be very beneficial but
actually there's a lot of clinical
evidence that shows an increasing amount
of clinical evidence that shows that
it's incredibly helpful for people with
dementia so very specific things
symptoms that are very common for people
who are living with dementia like
agitation and anxiety music can directly
benefit those and reduce those sometimes
it can you know create a need for less
medical intervention you know instead of
kind of silently take tablets for those
things music can can help and as you say
you know there's there's research all
the time that it shows an increasing
amount of ways that it can it can be
used in the fight against dementia yeah
it's those around them as well it helps
from thinking about the carers and the
families who are also living with
dementia can be of huge benefit to their
well-being as well exactly I mean what a
stressful situation to be in and so many
people who were in that situation
talking about 850,000 people right now
who were living with dementia in the UK
it'll be a million by 2025 so then you
add to that the second ripple out which
is all of those kind of carers and
family members who are living with that
person and supporting them and of course
you know musics so beneficial and this
idea of making playlists together is a
lovely thing because actually one of the
difficulties that you have when you're
you know living with something like
dementia is that ability to connect
sometimes that can be robbed by you know
the illness could kind of take that away
so actually the fact that you can
experience music together share it you
know that can kind of last for a really
long time and be a wonderful thing to
share with your loved one and this is
something you've actually done yourself
you've got a personal connection to this
because this is
something you did with your dad before
he died last year is that experience
like as a father-daughter experience
yeah no it was lovely so my dad had
kidney disease so it's a little bit
different but certainly you know having
the ability to use music as part of his
care at the end of his life was
massively powerful and for both of us I
mean actually I wasn't thinking about
the benefits that it might have for me
or for my mum who was caring for him but
you know when we first started working
on that playlist by the end of the day
at the beginning of the day I'd felt so
kind of desperate and unhappy and
thought right I'm going to do this
because it's what I do for a living it's
the only thing I could think of to do by
the end of the day you know we'd had
some kind of fantastic moments like
laughing about certain memories and him
a little dance along to a couple of
tracks you know it sound like and and my
mom was in the kitchen you know dancing
to Stevie Wonder and actually we'd
started off that day just feeling awful
and terrible and it really helped and
obviously you know anyone who's lived
with someone with a serious health
condition understands that day-to-day
there's so much to think about isn't
there you're thinking about what if they
had to drink what if they had to eat
have they slept how were they feeling
you're responding to all those kind of
very urgent issues but music is
something that's really important and
actually if we haven't thought of doing
that on that day then you know we might
never have had those experiences so it's
it's that kind of thing I just remember
to kind of have this on your list if you
can do it with your love from while
they're well enough it can be massively
powerful and now for me now that my dad
is gone the playlist is still there you
know and when I listen to it it's it's
this kind of close as I can feel to him
to spend time with us music what are
some of the favorite tracks on there oh
man I mean everything is massive music
no my dad but a bit Steely Dan bit of
Bob Dylan you know some kind of great
folk like classic blues and you're still
adding to it yeah it's a great way of
continuing his memory and legacy every
now and again I'll be like oh my god I
can't believe we forgot to put our next
record then I'll stick that oh nice
that's really lovely
it's interesting isn't it cuz obviously
you present Desert Island Discs and that
whole show is based on how me pieces of
music and songs can take you map to a
certain time and evoke memories and so
you know working through this playlist
with somebody living with dementia
carers extended family and friends will
no doubt bring out stories that perhaps
haven't been told before
exactly it's all that kind of stuff you
know it's the stuff of life you think
about all the big moments in our lives
they're always soundtracks by music you
know whether you think about wedding a
birthday party music festivals those are
the times that we kind of come together
and have really important life
experiences so as you say like a perfect
opportunity to share those kind of
memories and stories and then also
sometimes just the idea of sitting with
someone and listening to something
together when you can't do other things
you know you might not be able to have
the conversation that you used to have
but actually you still share something
and that's that's really powerful
you know dementia affects more than
850,000 people in the UK every year set
to reach a million by 2025 and as
ambassador for music for dementia and
obviously when we talk about playlist a
lot of people go off but no idea how
they don't like yeah not sure about that
I even struggle sometimes and but you've
come out with a handy guide where can
people find information about that and
they can find nice and easy exactly we
are making it really easy all sorts of
how-to guides on the music for dementia
2020 website so that's music for
dementia 2020 comm Lauren really good to
talk to you thank you very much a
positive story about living with
dementia and what everybody can do to
make life that little bit easy of course
always more poignant in the build-up to
Christmas in the new year thank you
Lauren